بعد ثلاث سنوات على واحده من اكثر عمليات
السطو اثاره والتي كان مسرحها متحف بمدينه
ديرستن شرق المانيا اعلنت السلطات في
البلاد ان الشرطه اثرت في العاصمه برلين
مؤخرا على جزء كبير من المجوهرات النفيسه
المسروقه وفقا لما اعلنت الشرطه والمدعي
العام في درسدن فقد تم العثور على احدى
وثلاثين قطعه كامله او منقوصه من بينها
وسام النسر الابيض المرصع بالماس على شكل
نجمه صدر ويشتبه في ان سته متهمين اقتحموا
متحف القبض الاخضر الشهير وسرقوا من احدى
وعشرين جوهره مرصعه لاكثر من اربعه الاف
وثلث بقيمه اجماليه تبلغ حوالي 120 مليون
دولار رغم ان المتهمين التزموا صمطا خلال
المحاكمه الى ان سرطاها تسترجعت معظم
القطع المسروقه بفض ما سميت بمحدثات
استكشافيه اجريت بين فريقين الدفاع
والادعاء